[Music]  et hit the after-party for the  Victoria's Secret Fashion Show in Paris  Wednesday where we caught up with it  Gigi and Yolanda Hadid there seemed like  a beautiful moment where you first came  out and you looked over at your mom  a lot of kisses too she makes people  feel at home oh my friend Bella Hadid  was also there rocking this bejeweled  look that left very little to the  imagination goodness and arena shake  shut off a hint of a baby bump in her  own sexy ensemble kinda we've been here  for like three minutes are you okay okay  now kendall Jenner might have had a food  baby after going in on a burgers and  fries and other carbs after the show  around to around town oh how we wish the  Schumer sisters had been there  Amy shared this silly snap captioned at  nervous for the big fashion show with  the hadees and kylie hashtag so hungry  hashtag mama will alert early